Let's go next to Mackenzie.
Mackenzie, you were on the air.
Mackenzie, I heard you just for a second there,
you're on the air.
Oh, no, David, oh, no, David, you caught me.
You caught me in some dough.
I'm sorry, you're literally me.
Are you Canadian?
Yes, sir.
Oh, you are.
You're you're like I didn't switch myself
to just listening.
So, sir, you're literally making bagels right
now.
You betcha.
Yeah, that is unbelievable.
And so is that.
You boil and then you bake.
I boil, yes, and then I think that's incredible
and what flavors are you making?
We've got everything going on right now, black
sesame, sesame and some some onion and garlic.
Is this is this is your job to make bagels
or you just do this, like for home?
Yeah.
This is my job.
I'm a baker.
Oh, OK.
That's fantastic.
Yeah.
I always listen while I work it's the best.
And then I was covered in flour.
Couldn't switch to just listening.
This is fascinating.
What part of Canada are you in.
Right in the middle, not Toronto.
Not Vancouver.
OK.
All right, fair enough.
And you can get a good little China, whatever.
You can get a good bagel in that part of Canada
since I moved back from Australia.
Yeah, I love it.
I love it.
All right.
Thanks for the chess games, by the way.
I had you on a couple of multiphase.
We had a couple of good ones.
Oh, beautiful.
Who won?
You took the last two and I didn't go for
the rematch.
OK, that's fair.
That's fair.
All right, listen, bagel's we I love.
I'm glad I stumbled across this because I
love bagel's.
I'll have something more useful for you next
time.
OK, thank you very much.
There's cheers, Brother McKenzie.
The baker didn't even want to talk to me.
Sort of forced him into it.
Crazy.